[Música]
hace seis meses exactos rusia invadió a
ucrania el collado de seguridad de la
onu 4 la situación en la de la planta
nuclear de saturn y allá el embajador
ucraniano afirmó que si los prorrusos
juzgan a los prisioneros de guerra moscú
cruzaría un punto de no retorno mientras
que el presidente es el ex y denunció un
ataque contra una estación de trenes que
deja 22 muertos
en chile detuvieron al líder mapuche
héctor llaitul lo acusan de robar madera
mientras que la coordinadora arauco
malleco que él encabeza pidió continuar
con los sabotajes a las empresas
madereras del sur del país analizamos en
minutos
una caravana de la presidencia de
colombia fue atacada a tiros en el
noreste del país cerca de la frontera
con venezuela el ejecutivo confirmó que
la comitiva ya está a salvo este hecho
ocurre horas después de que españa se
ofreciera a ser la sede de los diálogos
con la guerrilla de la ln que tiene
influencia en la zona
bienvenidos a la actualidad informativa
en france 24 yo soy maría clara calle y
es un placer acompañarlos comenzamos en
ucrania donde se cumplen seis meses
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa a
propósito de la fecha y revisando medio
año del conflicto el consejo de
seguridad de la onu se reunió en nueva
york' allí el embajador ucraniano afirmó
que si los gobiernos pro rusos del
donbass juzgan a los prisioneros de
guerra que tienen esto marcaría un punto
de no retorno en los diálogos mientras
que el presidente de volodymyr selenski
que asistió virtualmente a la cita
denunció un nuevo ataque que dejó 22
fallecidos la onu precisó que hasta
ahora han muerto al menos cinco mil 614
civiles en toda la guerra y que el 40
por ciento de la población necesita
ayuda humanitaria
este miércoles mientras su gran ya
celebraba su día de independencia y el
conflicto cumplía su sexto mes la ciudad
de nueva york acogió un nuevo consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas para
mejorar los estragos de la invasión rusa
durante este periodo devastador miles de
civiles han muerto y han resultado
heridos entre ellos cientos de niños y
otros innumerables han perdido a sus
familiares amigos y seres queridos en la
reunión participó por videoconferencia
al presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski que denunció que en el día
grande de ucrania rusia siguió atacando
infraestructuras civiles en el centro
del país he recibido información de que
rusia ha lanzado misiles contra la
región de mi propia trops contra la
estación de tren contra los valores de
la estación
y 50 personas resultaron heridas por
desgracia el número de muertos podría
aumentar
esta es nuestra vida diaria así es como
rusia se preparó para esta sesión de la
onu
los representantes de los países
miembros plantearon un amplio abanico de
preocupaciones en materia de seguridad a
todas las escalas la cuestión de la
planta nuclear de satori ya tapada por
los rusos desde marzo obtuvo un capítulo
especial sin embargo entre los
embajadores de rusia y ucrania
continuaron los reproches cruzados quien
está perdiendo la batalla por las mentes
y sus patrocinadores occidentales que
están librando una guerra por encargo
contra rusia con el último ucraniano se
están enfangando cada vez más en el
apoyo a este régimen anti popular y anti
humano haciendo la vista gorda ante las
manifestaciones del neonazismo
nacionalismo extremo y ruso fobia
y
[Música]
seguimos comprometidos con la soberanía
independencia la unidad y la integridad
territorial de ucrania dentro de sus
fronteras internacionalmente reconocidas
que se extienden hasta sus límites
territoriales hoy una vez más reiteramos
nuestra exigencia del cese inmediato de
hostilidades
mientras la onu llama a rebajar las
tensiones el conflicto en el terreno que
ya entró en su séptimo mes parece estar
lejos de llegar a su fin y en las
noticias relacionadas con la guerra
según el periódico lemont un yacimiento
de gas que pertenece en parte al gigante
energético francés total energy sse está
siendo utilizado para suministrar
combustible a los bombarderos rusos la
compañía niega las afirmaciones y dice
que no tiene control sobre las
actividades de la empresa rusa a la que
le vende el gas veamos
es una acusación dirigida directamente a
una de las mayores empresas de francia
que ahora es señalada por ayudar a la
aviación rusa a lanzar ataques en
territorio ucraniano es una
investigación realizada por la
organización internacional global
witness junto a periodistas franceses y
publicada en el periódico galo lemont
total ahora rebautizada como autor
energies es supuestamente co propietaria
de un yacimiento siberiano donde se
extrae el condensado de gas una mezcla
de hidrocarburos antes de ser refinado
por una empresa rusa para convertirlo en
combustible para motores de los aviones
la investigación ha descubierto que
cientos de cargamentos de combustible se
envían a dos bases aéreas en la frontera
ucraniana y que por ello se utilizan
como parte de la invasión de moscú
aunque el gigante energético ha
confirmado que el condensado de gas se
vende a la empresa rusa novotek en la
que posee una participación del 20 por
ciento total en el gis afirma que no
tiene ningún control sobre sus
actividades operativas
tenemos acceso a estos datos simplemente
porque los compramos a un proveedor de
datos que se utiliza ampliamente en la
industria por lo tanto que total diga
que no puede ver a dónde van los envíos
dos datos creo que es muy sorprendente
sobre todo cuando están hablando de una
empresa de la que son dueños del 20%
el informe afirma que el combustible se
ha utilizado para alimentar aviones de
combate implicados en bombardeos contra
poblaciones civiles incluido un ataque
que mató a 47 personas en marzo a
diferencia de otras empresas energéticas
total se ha negado a retirarse de rusia
como respuesta a la guerra en marzo su
director ejecutivo dijo que los
yacimientos de gas funcionarán
independientemente de que la empresa se
fuera o no e insistió en que siguen
siendo vitales para el suministro de
energía europa pasamos a chile porque la
policía detuvo a héctor llaitul uno de
los principales líderes mapuche
destacado por su radicalismo que hay
tules además el líder de la llamada
coordinadora arauco malleco una
agrupación indigenista que reivindica
algunos ataques incendiarios contra
latifundistas en el sur de chile allí
históricamente ha habido un conflicto
entre la etnia que considera como
ancestrales las tierras que las empresas
explotan para la producción de madera y
precisamente ya hay tul es indicado de
robar esa materia prima para entender un
poco más de la problemática nos acompaña
desde la capital chilena nicolás freire
él es doctor en estudios americanos de
la universidad de santiago bienvenido
aquí a france 24 y gracias por estar con
nosotros tras el arresto la coordinadora
que lidera llaitul invito a continuar
los sabotajes contra las empresas que
trató entonces se podría escalar este
conflicto
una manera clara gracias por la
invitación efectivamente es una
situación bastante intrincada la cría
que tenemos frente a lo que es esta
detención de llaitul y sobre todo porque
no es solamente un tema judicial sino
que también es un tema político
efectivamente vivía vimos a la ministra
del interior teniendo que referirse a
esta detención que también vale la pena
decirlo es una detención que viene de
una querella de hace dos años es decir
desde hace dos años atrás que la
fiscalía habría podido actuar frente a
las acciones oa las interrogantes que se
tengan en el actuar de jay tur lo hace
hoy día porque también ha existido una
presión mediática importante y una
presión que él mismo y aitor con algunos
comentarios por ejemplo esto referido a
que el robo de madera se bien servía
para sustentar y financiar las armas y
las y las balas de la guerrilla que
vélez en la araucanía ha generado una
política importante que agregamos
envuelto también acciones del gobierno
que ha querido mantener en la araucanía
desde el inicio desde los 2 de marzo una
lógica de acuerdo ideal o muy bueno y
diez acuerdos y diálogo sinceramente se
rompe efectivamente a partir de esta
dirección y tal como usted lo dice hay
un componente político bastante
importante y también mencionó que en
2020 todo el caso comenzó por una
denuncia del entonces gobierno de
sebastián piñera pero ahora en julio la
administración de gabriel boric la
amplió a pesar de que una de sus
banderas de campaña fue rechazar el
estado de excepción que usó su antecesor
como y porque ha sido el cambio de
postura de boris en este caso
si efectivamente el gobierno actual del
gobierno del presidente gabriel boric en
un momento inicial seguía con esta
lógica del diálogo se le criticó mucho
no querer tomar acciones frente a dichos
no sólo estuvo último sino que otro que
se había manifestado y aitor llamando a
la resistencia ramadán llamando al
sabotaje de distintas empresas en la
araucanía y el gobierno estuvo un tanto
inmóvil inicialmente pero posteriormente
viene una crítica importante hay que
recordar que este gobierno tiene dos
almas en su coalición y la coalición un
poco más moderada lo que es socialismo
democrático donde está no el partido
comunista sino que el partido socialista
el partido liberal empezaron también a
presionar respecto de la toma de
acciones por parte del gobierno y diría
en condiciones en el que el gobierno se
ha visto digamos presionado por la
opinión pública presionado por los
medios de comunicación y presionados
también por un plebiscito a la vuelta de
la esquina su crédito constitucional si
evidentemente adoptado una estrategia
distinta señor freire gracias por
acompañarnos
muchas gracias a ustedes y pasamos al
norte de colombia donde atacaron a una
caravana presidencial que se dirigía
hacia el municipio de el tarra seis
hombres armados instalaron un retén
ilegal y cuando los vehículos no
frenaron dos de ellos recibieron
disparos con armas de largo alcance el
gobierno de gustavo petro que no se ha
encontrado en la comitiva agregó que
inicialmente uno de los conductores fue
retenido y que luego lo liberaron
el hecho se registró en el sector san
pablo el tarra cuando por lo menos seis
sujetos tendrían instalado un retén
ilegal la caravana hizo caso omiso al
padre motivo por el cual fueron
impactados con arma de fuego
esto ocurre después de que el presidente
colombiano gustavo petro recibiera la
oferta de españa para hacer la sede de
los diálogos con la guerrilla de la ln
un grupo armado que de hecho tiene
injerencia en la zona del ataque aunque
no es el único es que el jefe del
gobierno español pedro sánchez le hizo
la propuesta a su homólogo durante la
reunión que sostuvieron en bogotá como
parte de su gira latinoamericana luego
de esto petro también anunció que le
propuso a eeuu no extraditar a los
narcotraficantes que negocian con su
gobierno y que se comprometan a no
reincidir en sus acciones ilegales
palabras en el marco de la visita de una
delegación antidrogas de la casa blanca
de bogotá
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
la condonación de la deuda de préstamos
estudiantiles para unos 43 millones de
personas veamos
un alivio para los estudiantes
estadounidenses me quitaron un peso de
encima principalmente para mis padres
porque los estresa mucho
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que perdonará deudas de préstamos a
estudiantes universitarios y recién
graduados el gobierno federal estima que
43 millones de personas se verán
beneficiadas del plan
el costo total para asistir a una
universidad pública de 4 años se ha
triplicado durante los últimos 40 años
en lugar de financiar adecuadamente las
universidades públicas muchos estados
han recortado su apoyo y han reducido la
financiación para sus universidades
estatales dejando que los estudiantes
paguen una mayor parte de la cuenta
esta nueva medida está pensada para
aquellos que ganen menos de 125 mil
dólares de forma individual o 250.000 en
familia anualmente y espera cancelar
10.000 dólares en préstamos y 10.000
adicionales para estudiantes con becas
federales ppl reservadas para quienes
tienen mayores necesidades financieras
el anuncio de bailén ha causado gran
polémica
no le ha dado una autorización explícita
para sus detractores es visto como un
guiño al voto joven a poco más de dos
meses de las elecciones legislativas
mientras economistas advirtieron que la
medida podría aumentar la inflación la
que llegó al 8.5 por ciento en julio los
republicanos pusieron en duda la
autoridad legal del mandatario para
tomar la decisión
los combates en el norte de etiopía se
reanudaron entre los rebeldes de tigre y
el gobierno rompiendo así una tregua de
5 meses
después de cinco meses de cese de
hostilidades los combates se reanudaron
en la región del tigre en el norte de
etiopía la comunidad internacional como
los locales han condenado los ataques y
temen que la situación sea grave
[Música]
estoy profundamente conmocionados y
entristecidos y enérgicamente el cese
inmediato de las hostilidades y la
reanudación de las negociaciones de paz
entre el gobierno y el frente popular de
liberación de tigre garantizando al
mismo tiempo el pleno acceso humanitario
a las poblaciones afectadas
el conflicto en tigre empezó en
noviembre de 2020 cuando el primer
ministro ahmed ali envió al ejército
para desalojar a las autoridades en la
región acusando las de atacar bases
militares después de retirarse
inicialmente los rebeldes recuperaron el
control casi total en 2021 el conflicto
provocó una grave crisis humanitaria con
6 millones de personas aisladas de
servicios básicos el conflicto dejó al
menos 1500 personas muertas más de
200.000 desplazadas y 350.000 se
enfrentan al hambre al hambre no hay
nada más grande que la paz la guerra
cobra vidas imaginero y daña al país
sabemos lo que es la guerra ya hemos
pasado por ella el director general de
la organización mundial de la salud que
es del tigre criticó la semana pasada la
falta de atención frente a la peor
crisis humanitaria del mundo
puedo decirles que la crisis humanitaria
en tigre es más grave que la de ucrania
sin exagerar y lo dije hace muchos meses
tal vez la razón sea el color de la piel
de la gente en ti grave no escuchado en
los últimos meses ni siquiera un jefe de
estado hablando sobre la condición de
tigre en ninguna parte
la oms pidió 123 millones de dólares
para abordar los problemas de salud
derivados de la creciente desnutrición
en la región donde viven alrededor de
200 millones de personas
sigan con nosotros
[Música]